benvenuti ad una nuova puntata del
leccio conca ribusa vorrei iniziare
questo episodio come una domanda dove
cavolo son finiti film di arti marziali
è uno dei miei generi preferiti e al
cinema non si vede quasi nulla so che
ormai le arti marziali sono un po
passate di moda al cinema un po come il
western ma porca miseria c'è stato un
periodo della mia adolescenza che non
facevo altro che scoprire nuovi talenti
involontariamente a 14 anni era un
talent scout degli attori di arti
marziali
passavo le ore su internet a cercare i
siti www.qualitapa.gov.it in occidente
mi capitavano sottomano sempre gli
stessi due jet li e jackie chan e appena
finito di vederne uno mi chiudevo
piangendo in posizione fetale sul letto
perché sapevo che non sarei mai potuto
riuscire a fare quelle cose lì nella
vita vera
o meglio avrei potuto tranquillamente
farlo spezzando mileti b provandoci ed
essendo io in europa era anche difficile
reperirli questi film asiatici
quindi sono andato a cercarmi altri
attori occidentali tipo jean claude van
damme e steven seagal che mannaggia la
miseria quell'uomo non c'è manco più
l'attaccatura dei capelli umana ma alla
fine mi ha accontentato di tutto quello
che vi capitava sotto mano e ovviamente
venne a conoscenza di bruce lee quando
io ero più piccolo bruce lee era ovunque
ormai ho perso il conto di quante volte
hanno dato i suoi film in televisione e
i suoi dvd vi edicola e fate conto che
bruce lee in occidente ha fatto sì e no
5 film ma andiamo con ordine
bruce lee è letteralmente una leggenda
nel mondo delle arti marziali non solo
come attore ma anche come rappresentante
delle arti marziali nonché portavoce
della filosofia che c'è dietro le arti
marziali in occidente sia con i film sia
con i libri e tutto questo è riuscito a
farlo a cavallo tra gli anni 60 e gli
anni 70 c'è il periodo è peggiore per le
discriminazioni razziali in america per
i neri e per gli asiatici
l'essere riuscito a entrare nei cuori e
nelle menti delle persone
l'ha fatto diventare il portavoce di un
vera cultura ma non ce ne frega un cazzo
quando eravamo piccoli nelle questioni
razziali in quel periodo delle
recensioni erano molto più semplici in
questo film c'è bruce lee
sì in questo film sam è meno sì in
questo film bruce lee usi nunchaku sì un
capolavoro d'arte moderna 5 stelle
ammonta a 10 su 10 e dovevo ricordarci
che bruce lee non solo ha fatto tutto
questo nella sua vita ma ha portato in
occidente uno dei suoni più importanti
della nostra vita
io l'ho buttata sul ridere ma quelle
veramente uno dei suoni più iconici
della storia del cinema e non ha portato
solo quello nelle famiglie italiane
bruce lee noaa ha portato anche il fatto
che ogni singolo bambino volesse fare
arti marziali e che ogni singola madre
chiamasse quelle arti marziali karate do
non voglio dire se tutte le console che
in casa sono il nintendo va benissimo
carapelli dicevo prima i fan di bruce
lee sono in realtà molto pochi quelli
che sono arrivati in occidente e quali
sono abbiamo il furore della cina
colpisce ancora
dalla cina con furore l'urlo di chen
terrorizza anche l'occidente e vorrei
ricordarvi che quel film finisce con
bruce lee che combatte contro chuck
norris nel colosseo e civil war kids i
tre dell'operazione drago e l'ultimo
combattimento dicendo quello che
qualcuno può non sapere è che bruce lee
data la sua fama al cinema è stato preso
per recitare in una serie americana
chiamata il calabrone verde dove faceva
il celeberrimo kato
ma quello che ha ancora meno gente sa è
che c'è stato un crossover nel calabrone
verde con il batman di adam west e si
può trovare un episodio in cui bruce lee
lotta contro robin no dicevo civil war
kids ma quello di cui voglio parlarvi
oggi in particolare è quello che è
successo durante e dopo il film l'ultimo
combattimento di cenna conosciuto anche
come game over
questo effettivamente l'ultimo film di
bruce lee c'è un piccolissimo problema
però bruce lee e morto durante le
riprese
e quello che sono riusciti a recuperare
soltanto di filmato sono poco più di 11
minuti
vi vedo seduti sulla vostra scrivania
chiede di
come può piccini voi che vi chiedete
come hanno fatto a concludere il film se
l'attore principale è morto
la risposta avete nei primi sei minuti
del film il film inizia con il finale di
un altro film l'urlo di chen terrorizza
anche l'occidente appunto subito dopo il
combattimento contro chuck norris che
probabilmente ha perso perché non aveva
la barba ai meme di chuck norris sempre
verbi e si copre che quel film era un
film infatti si trovano su un set
cinematografico io vi prego di non
battere le ciglia perché potreste
perdervi uno dei momenti più belli della
storia del cinema
so you can find lei
io non sono non solo non sono pienamente
sicuro se voi abbiate visto per davvero
cosa è successo in quella scena li
guardate me e guardate me ve lo spiego
io praticamente sì come avevano poco
girato di bruce lee prima della morte
hanno usato per ragguagliare le scene
pezzi dei film vecchi di bruce lee
ridoppiati adeguando il dialogo ma
siccome in questa scena all'asciugamano
e nella clip che hanno preso loro no
hanno appiccicato un asciugamano fasullo
sulla pellicola poi letteralmente vedere
l'asciugamano fermo immobile sopra il
corpo di bruce lee che si muove io non
so neanche dove cazzo mi trovo in questo
momento sono molto contento di poter
condividere questa cosa con voi
grazie ma siccome i sogni son desideri
non è finita qua per non utilizzare
tutte le clip dei vecchi film di bruce
lee ri doppiate perché forse era un
tantinello illegale hanno usato tre
diversi attori per interpretare bruce
lee e vi ripeto per favore non battete
gli occhi
tricesimo st voleva processo hanno
ritagliato un cartonato della faccia di
bruce lee el hanno appiccicato al vetro
del 7 ed hanno messo davanti alla faccia
dell'attore che di nuovo non si muove il
cartonato no questo non è un film
questa è la rappresentazione visiva del
walhalla per me e queste cose io quando
le avevo viste la prima volta da piccolo
non me n'ero neanche accorto ma come
cazzo fatto non accorgermi che quello
una merda di cartonato appiccicata sullo
specchio ma fortunatamente il resto del
film non è così ringraziando iddio come
ho detto prima si susseguono questi tre
attori che si spacciano per bruce lee i
problemi che non ci assomigliano e voi
direte beh grazie al cavolo non ci
assomigliano non solo lui sì ma bruce
lee per gli asiatici è l'equivalente di
michael jackson per gli occidentali
lui è meta chiunque poi io non sono
razzista e voi lo sapete porca miseria
solo un pugliese che è andato ad abitare
in piemonte che ha un nome arabo quindi
meno razzista di me non credo che ci sia
nessuno però te li tieni dalla bocca se
cose qui come hai fatto a non trovare un
asiatico uguale a un'altra asiatico per
detto bruce lee e quindi questi poveri
figuranti sono costretti a recitare ea
lottare tutto il tempo con degli
occhiali da sole giganti il problema è
che questi qui ci hanno gli occhiali di
giorno di notte all'interno all'esterno
che sembrano dei tamarri di torino che
minchia frate faccio after e sin tra
l'altro non è neanche malaccio perché i
combattimenti sono anche i cani gi
e poi c'è tutta la parte finale che è
praticamente un enorme il videogioco
dove c'è l'effettivo bruce lee e perché
sono gli undici minuti di girato che
sono riusciti a girare appunto e della
fantastica oserei dire scena della
pagoda dove bruce lee supera di livello
in livello il di piano in piano nemici
sempre più forti fino al boss finale
come dimenticare poi che uno dei suoi
avversari era karim aggiunge bar con i
suoi quanti 7 8 metri d'altezza più o
meno ma non vi ho detto l'ultima chicca
di
il film durante la tra durante lo
svolgimento della trama succede una cosa
al protagonista viene sparato in faccia
durante le riprese di un film perché
questi qua lo voleva uccidere lui viene
soltanto ferito in faccia ma per
infiltrarsi tra di loro si finge morto e
vince anche il suo funerale
il problema è che le scene del funerale
nel film sono le vere scene del vero
funerale di bruce lee con tanto di
inquadratura della salma io da quando ho
scoperto questa cosa qui che mi chiedo
come porca di una e legale
questa cosa qui
e questo l'ultimo combattimento di chen
è effettivamente l'ultimo film di bruce
lee
ma come diceva corrado e non finisce qui
siccome a quanto pare per interpretare
qualcuno basta mettere un cartonato
appiccicato ad uno specchio perché
fermarci a bruce lee in quel modo lì poi
limitare il cazzo che ti pare no ma è
meglio dire sono pieno di soldi paga
bimbo va bene va bene va bene
ho parlato con l'avvocato ha detto che
possiamo denunciare il team ha fatto
qualcosa si perdono di carta non volevo
prendi tu tum premier ma alla fine poi
qualcuno le ha comprate le macchine a
idrogeno di come le schifezza e
permettere di più io non lo faccio
abbastanza maschile per evitarla plata o
globo e sono da cinquant'anni mediaset e
ancora mi fanno vendere materassi si
dove cazzo è finita la mia carriera
mannaggia miseria che mi sto sforzando
avesse il nuovo troisi ma proprio non ce
la faccio non so perché no perché i
nostri testi fa cagare
ed ecco nomi delle imitazioni
cristalline che voi sareste neanche
riusciti a dividere le persone vere da
quelle della vita totalmente
hai visto che la figlia aveva ragione
film si può fare si può fare
dopo la morte di bruce lee è l'ultimo
combattimento di chen sono arrivati
tanti ma tanti altri film con bruce lee
come attore e quindi diamo il benvenuto
a quello che il mondo chiama labruce
playstation o come piace chiamarla me
giocare al necrofilo con bruce lee
tra i tanti film che sono usciti postumi
c'è per esempio game of death due in
seguito dell'ultimo combattimento
dicembre ovviamente anche questo è fatto
con spezzoni di vecchi film di bruce lee
ridoppiati ma lui ovviamente non c'è
piccolissimo particolare di questa
pellicola è che i blues li fasullo è
stato doppiato in italiano da massimo
lopez a caso completamente a casa e un
video di signore incredibile poi abbiamo
il cloni di bruce lee con interpreti
quali bruce lee dragon ii plus live e
questi romeni sono inventati sono
proprio i nomi iscritti in ogni singolo
film di bruce lee dopo la morte perché
ovviamente per motivi legali non
potevano mettere il suo vero nome però
cercavano di attirare la gente comunque
poi abbiamo bruce lee
l'uomo il mito con tanto di locandina
che dice bruce lee
vi ricordate in tre dell'operazione
drago ecco quel film in originale si
chiama inter vedremo potevano lasciar
stare uno dei suoi film più famosi ecco
subito i suoi due seguiti loro ufficiali
exit des dragons enter the tiger è
diventata una porta scorrevole entra
esce la gente che il cazzo gli pare e
poi in seguito con simon che uno degli
attori di arti marziali per in carne che
c'è è infatti il film si chiama enter
the fact dragons e qui un applauso ci
vuole perché guarda e poi personalmente
il mio preferito perché comunque questi
film di potete trovare in giro anche in
versione dvd ei è incredibile il drago
vive ancora questo è un vero e proprio
film postumo perché la trama è bruce lee
che si risveglia nell'aldilà e
nell'aldilà bruce lee incontra persone
del calibro di
james bond il padrino clean
facebook l'esorcista cazzo di braccio di
ferro e non gli vuoi mettere qualche
nemico è certo infatti in questo film
bus villotte racconto armate di
scheletri capitanate dal dracula e da
satana
io voglio i nomi voglio i nomi dei
responsabili di questo casino se tu ci
pensi un attimo questori è incredibile
pensa se la facessimo noi adesso una
cosa del genere
vi ricordate di antonio de curtis bene
perché lui è tornato e vuole distruggere
la città in anticipo eccovi una clip del
film ma mi faccia il piacere mi faccia
totò contro tutti italiani morpher dio
che è strozzato